well apparently these days to excite all
the geeks in the room all i have to do
is go
duh
[Music]
so
marvel's starting to lay actual
groundwork for mutants or at least
they're hinting that it's coming
uh minor spoiler this is kind of an
easter egg it's not actually impactful
on the plot but minor spoiler for the
final episode of ms marvel but at the
very end of that we had kamala khan be
told by her tech friend bruno that so
far as he could tell despite his earlier
estimation of where her powers come from
he said that there was something that
was a mutation in her genes he used that
word specifically kamala there's
something different in your genes
like
like a mutation and we got that little
musical rift
from the 90s x-men cartoon
[Music]
the same rift that of course also
appeared when professor x showed up in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
so while the multiverse madness thing
could have been shrugged off as just
like a fun easter eggy thing and not
necessarily an indication of what was to
come in the future this
like a mutation
this is more meaningful because this is
the same continuity as the rest of the
mcu
so
i'm going to talk about a few things
here i'm going to talk about
what we know so far what i feel it
indicates for how they may or may not
bring in the x-men talk about some of
the possibilities why i think certain
ideas would be better than others and
some of the problems with some things
that i see floated out there in fan
spaces
so
i've actually kind of done this before
way back when it was first confirmed
that disney was going to be acquiring
fox and getting the x-men uh licensing
back i did a couple of videos on this so
i've visited this topic before but it's
been a while and that was completely
speculative back then now
i've got a little bit more to work with
because
as i said we're getting actual
groundwork laid in a universe that i
understand and i feel like
i can say some things about how they may
or may not choose to do this the first
thing we should really take off the
table immediately which is good because
i think it would have been the worst way
to do it
i think we need to very seriously take
off the table at least for now the
possibility that the x-men or any
mutants are going to be brought into
existence by crossing over from another
reality because of the multiverse that's
something that i've seen floated since
the very beginning of disney reacquiring
fox that was actually the reason why
people said it would be the same x-men
as had already been established so you
know hugh jackman's wolverine
patrick stewart's professor x etc etc
we can't expect that to happen
i'll i'll say what i said before
marvel would be much better served by
building their own versions of these
you know there's a certain amount of
nostalgia you can get out of the fox
stuff and i mean obviously they brought
patrick stewart back and got a good pop
for doing that but
how many movies do you think he's
actually gonna sign on to do they're
gonna want people to commit to multiple
films and hugh jackman really did very
thoroughly sign off the part of
wolverine already
but even beyond that
one of the major points of
doctor strange of the multiverse of
madness was that incursions which is the
word for when person from one universe
travels over to other universes i.e
traverses the multiverse
that is a massive inherent problem and
actually threatens the very fabric of
reality in the universe that the
incursion has crossed over into so
the idea of a whole team of them coming
in and it not immediately ripping the
universe apart no they seem to have set
up rules that eliminates that as a
possibility at least for now now it is
of course feasible that there will be
some work around found for that in the
future maybe eventually when richard
shows up doing whatever
weird generic sciency stuff he finds a
way to stabilize it like yes all of that
is possible but it would be a very odd
choice for them to go and here's why it
won't be a multiversal crossover and
then find an excuse to
undo their own rule i guess you could
claim it's a misdirect but it seems like
more trouble than it's worth to do it
that way so i'm taking that off the
table right now
so that leaves us with a couple of
questions in terms of mutations starting
to happen in the mcu
and the big one
is whether or not these are a new thing
now in terms of the understanding of the
public
absolutely they're a new thing because
bruno
didn't know what to make of the fact
that there was a mutation in kamala so
this is definitely not something that's
known to the public
which is already a potentially little
bit of a problem in terms of how
the x-men and mutants in general are
supposed to work i mean a big part of
the appeal of the x-men is that they
basically become a stand-in for well
almost any
minority or press group that is feared
or um looked down upon by the general
populace it's worked as a metaphor for
various races familial backgrounds
religious groups queer people
but to have them suddenly appear out of
nowhere and not be something that's been
around for a while for prejudices to
kind of get embedded does undermined
that a little bit and to be clear that's
not a problem that would be solved if
you had them crossover from another
universe because you're still just
dealing with a situation of they just
show up
so this already has a potential issue in
terms of not necessarily the entire
point of the x-men but like a major
factor of why they're great and what the
appeal of them is
but at this point we're kind of stuck
with it because
the mcu has been going on far too long
for mutants to have just been a thing
that was around but hasn't been brought
up to now
like
phase two maybe they could have pulled
that off this point over a decade worth
of films 20 some odd and multiple series
now no
no they're not they're not going to get
away with that and i think they know it
which is why they probably have bruno
acting a little bit surprised the way
that he does
so that brings up the most obvious thing
is that mutations are a new thing that
is that is happening for the first time
now now that may or may not be the case
but it would track in terms of it
happening to kamala people don't seem to
know what this means overall or realize
that mutation is a thing that is uh
potential to hit any number of people in
the general populace so
that would be a little bit of an odd
thing because
um well they may or may not decide to uh
you know determine and signify and
isolate a trigger event but that would
kind of be turning the mutants into the
inhumans and
turning it into a thing like the
terrigen bomb which i don't think
they'll do i think they'll still have it
be genetics purely although the terrigen
bomb still involves genetics because it
only impacts people with inhuman the
right in human genes but i did
a whole other thing
so
did something set it off or is this
something that is just starting to
happen now and kamala is
around the right age for it to just kind
of happen to her i mean a little older
it can't happen you know as young as
puberty but you know teenaged
yeah
so that tracks for how mutation is
usually done both in the comics and how
it has traditionally been handled in
various media like the x-men movies that
were done over at fox
but
there's another problem beyond the
question of
well
does that diminish their use as a any
kind of civil rights stand-in as they
are often used as
because if it's just starting now
that really only opens us up
to young
mutants or even if you say mutation can
happen to someone at any age
it means that there's nobody who's been
around who's established because part of
the thing with x-men is you have it as a
generational thing depending on when you
pick up the comics at the very start of
the comics you had the elder generation
of mutants being folks like magneto and
charles xavier but then later on you had
the original team of x-men sort of
helping to teach a new generation later
on and it becomes a generational thing
and that's another aspect that's kind of
core
to the x-men like to have the x-men
without magneto and professor x
or some equivalent to them in the mix is
kind of a hard sell
but
if they have been around
why does it seem like mutations new
now an idea that i floated the last time
i talked about all this
was the following and i'm not
necessarily still going to say this is
what they should do but this was
something that i thought of and i still
kind of like this idea and i want to put
it on record again now that i have
significantly more followers than the
last time i talked about this
basically
the world
at large has a blind spot
for mutants and mutation
because of professor x he is using sabri
cerebro not only to
locate isolate and bring to a safe place
mutants as they occur across the planet
but he is also using it to amplify his
telepathic ability to basically just
create a perception filter around
anything having to do with mutation for
normal humans
it doesn't stick they don't remember
they don't notice
and so
that did also mean that part of my
proposal at the time was that
what causes people to start to take
notice of mutants
is that professor x gets assassinated
part of the reason i had that as a
proposal was because i'm not sure you're
ever going to cast better than patrick
stewart and yes i know james mcavoy he
was fine too but like come on there's a
reason they brought patrick stewart in
for the doctor strange he's the iconic
one even if you want to go with yeah
this is not the same one as the one from
fox's just the one in the mcu universe i
still have to wonder how many uh movies
he's gonna want to commit to versus how
many uh disney and marvel would want him
for
though even if he only signs on for one
or two maybe it would be big enough to
pop to be worth it but a way around that
is if he gets assassinated not only does
that cover having to recast but
additionally it would give us a catalyst
for why suddenly
the general population is realizing and
remembering and going wait a minute
i've known about this
why haven't we been doing anything about
it
which would cause the kind of general
panic that you would expect around
mutants now whether you choose to
assassinate them or not i do think
professor x's abilities especially
enhanced by something like cerebro could
feasibly be used as a reason for why
mutants are going unnoticed
but they have been around
although again if they've been unnoticed
for so long unless you do something to
undo
sort of the the mind uh manipulation
that professor x did
again this we're still completely within
speculation on my part uh you have to do
something to roll that back because
otherwise we're still in the same
situation where it loses that civil
rights aspect because even this way
there's still a problem of well if
people are only realizing it now then it
still seems like this is a sudden and
new thing
but
it would help a little bit if it was a
case of no it seems like a new thing to
you but they've been here the whole time
which
yeah that can work in a civil rights
context because
oftentimes groups that end up being used
as scapegoats
or labeled invaders be they
refugees or people of a certain religion
taking up residence in a country or
queer
people
trans people
etc
suddenly being called new and invasive
even though we've been here the whole
time no that could work
but there's another thing uh i mentioned
him
that's magneto
i've seen
for a while now
that people said well
he still has to be a survivor of the
holocaust and i agree in principle
but i think there's a little wiggle room
i agree in the principle that a
not only does magneto have to be the
survivor of an atrocity but more
important than that you gotta listen to
me on this it has to be
a real
world atrocity the quickest way to
completely undercut the meaning and
significance of magneto and part of what
makes him such a compelling character
and villain
is the fact that he survived something
that really happened a true
monstrosity committed by actual human
beings if you instead
make him a survivor of some kind of
atrocity that happened in
sokovia latvia any number of made-up
places
it's not the same it needs to be a
real-world genocide that he survived
now i think there are arguments to be
made to have it stay the holocaust
specifically because he's also an
incredibly significant jewish character
and i wouldn't want to take that away
that having been said strictly for the
purposes of his use as a villain
there's a slight issue in terms of
age
which is that we are now at a point
where even as a small child
you're looking at a
significantly
older character and actor than we've
usually dealt with with
magneto now is it impossible to overcome
i don't know it depends on how far out
years wise we are from an actual proper
x-men movie and given that we've had
announcements up through
2023 on stuff we're probably looking at
2024 2025 which means we're looking at
80 years since the end of world war ii
he would have had to have been old
enough to have strong memories so i'm
gonna say six or seven
you're dealing with somebody in their
mid to late eighties
that's tough now the easy answer is
something about his mutation either
helps him maintain youth or makes him
able to power through these things and
maybe use cgi to make somebody look a
little older that's possible that's
absolutely doable but i think an option
i'd at least like to see considered
is that magneto is the survivor of an
atrocity other than the holocaust this
is not to downplay the holocaust
never downplay the holocaust
but that
was neither the only
nor the last
genocide
that has happened on this planet
there have been genocides
all over the place across the decades
and
you could still have him be older than
your main leads but he could be a
survivor of genocide in zanzibar nigeria
algeria cambodia bangladesh burundi
indonesia papua new guinea heck you
could have him be an indigenous american
dealing with generational trauma i don't
have a
preference feels very weird to say
preference in relation to
genocides
but
i think that could at least be an option
all that having been said you know
the watchmen tv show did have
a character who was a survivor of the
tulsa massacre the character was dang
near a hundred
and it did work
so
it is still possible to have him be a
survivor of the holocaust and
with the right actor in place i wouldn't
oppose ian mckellen again nobody's
talking about extermination no one ever
talks about it
they just do it
but again similar to patrick stewart i'm
not going to presume that he would want
to come back for as many films as they
would want to get out of him
it could still work
but it has to be part of his background
that he survived a genocide and it has
to be
a real one coming back to ms marvel real
quick i am kind of half expecting in the
marvels that maybe the bonus scene at
the end of that might be kamalakon being
contacted by somebody tied to the x-men
or at least somebody who is an
established mutant wolverine would be
the obvious pick i mean kamala has
actually teamed up with him in the
comics so that's kind of fun in an
easter eggy way although for some reason
in my head like i really wanted to be
nightcrawler i don't know why
i like kurt
he's fun but i feel like overall i would
be very surprised if when
mutants and x-men get more firmly
established that it becomes a matter of
this is brand new and it's just starting
to happen maybe it starts happening on a
larger scale
on mass
maybe that's the other way you do it
that there have been mutants up to this
point but they have been so few and far
between
and they are something that the few
people in say government authorities
knew about that kept a lid on and they
have
worked very hard to stay out of the
public eye
so
maybe with kamala that's not necessarily
the signal that mutants are new for the
first time but rather
it's proliferating and now there's going
to be too many
of them to hide
that's possible but in any case i don't
expect that we're gonna like
see the initial formation of the x-men
now
because
a big part of the appeal of them is the
history to them whether that history
comes in the form of older students who
have been at charles xavier school for
gifted youngsters for a while or whether
it simply comes in the form of charles
and eric
professor x and magneto themselves
the sense of history in the sense that
this has been around in some form for a
while is really kind of key and core to
the thing and in my mind it's largely
just a question of how they're going to
explain it not being more widespread and
it might just be flat out that it hasn't
happened that many times but now it's
happening more as far as x-men to bring
in i'd love to see them bring in some of
the ones who just haven't been milked to
death and like they're gonna do a
wolverine eventually that's just gonna
happen we have to assume that but you
know ones that have been more secondary
tertiary in the movies if they've shown
up at all so i'm talking about folks
like kitty pride iceman jubilee
gambit dazzler armor heck don't start
with the x-men at all start with the
brotherhood of evil mutants just for the
love of all things geeky
don't set up the dark phoenix saga again
we've had two big whiffs on that leave
it alone
for
ever
honestly
but a while
yeah
but that's starting to get into ideas of
storylines to do with x-men later and
that's
that could be it's it's own conversation
as a whole other thing because
i won't lie
i kind of liked when
the x-men were at fox and they were a
separate universe
because can we be honest
x-men generally work best when they're
basically treated in isolation
like there aren't other superheroes
around
most x-men stories
good and bad
focus on
the x-men
dealing with other mutants
the whole mutant thing
is kind of self-contained you have some
characters who interact with the rest of
the greater universe a little bit more
hank mccoy wolverine just because he's
super popular deadpool is kind of his
own thing at this point
but by and large
it's actually treated like when the
x-men and the avengers either team up or
fight as a really big deal
because it should be
because they kind of are best treated in
their own little bubbles
and so that's kind of why the idea of
integrating the x-men into the mcu has
never actually excited me all that much
because i don't think there's a lot that
is actually gained
by the x-men being able to interact with
all the other stuff going on in the mcu
now there's stuff to potentially be
gained in terms of fresh actors in these
parts
stories that haven't been adapted yet
fresh takes new ideas i'm all for that
but the actual integration of the x-men
or mutants in general into the mcu
isn't an idea that excites me
it never has been
because
i don't think it adds much to them
so much goes on with the x-men including
frigging
stuff
they don't need the rest of the mcu to
interact with
i think they kind of work better or a
little bit more streamlined the less you
do that
but at this point it's expected
eventually
when marvel starts handling these
characters and they're going to they're
too popular to not do something with
eventually
marvel is gonna have to deal with them
and it is going to have to be
handling them in the mcu
that's just going to have to be the case
from a strictly creative standpoint i
would actually argue it would be better
for them to be in a different multiverse
where there basically are no avengers
and it's just the x-men except that they
will never actually do that because fans
would be going why aren't you
integrating it and i get it
i still don't think it's the best idea
but it's gonna happen like it just is i
know that
you know no matter what i think is or
isn't the best thing i do try and keep
uh my finger on the pulse of what's
realistic
they're gonna get integrated
and i am curious to see how
but i've also got my concerns
just because of how late in the game
they're coming up how do we account for
that are they new what do we lose if
they're new if they've been around for a
while what's the deal there
specifics are going to matter here
but we're probably not going to know for
a while
i just wanted to talk about it because
well
it was on my mind because it's
definitely coming
probably not for some time like it's not
around the corner folks i mean it's not
you should try and keep in mind
how early thanos was teased
versus
actually mattering in the movies now i'm
not saying that the x-men are gonna be
like the next big major arc
of uh the mcu
kind of like uh you know how we had the
infinity saga for three phases and now
this seems to be the multiverse era that
we're now in i'm not necessarily
expecting the x-men to be the focus of
phase five
but depending on how they choose to have
the mutants be a thing
dealing with the fallout of them being
around
that could be the main thing to build
that around potentially but we would be
looking at a phase five situation which
who knows when the heck that officially
starts
what are your thoughts on any of this
the stuff i've said what are your ideas
what do you think they should do
whatever your thoughts are draw
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills
that is what enables me to do this as my
living and have videos for you every
single saturday
but uh you can help me out even without
contributing to the patreon i would
certainly appreciate if you did you get
early access to videos like this one but
even if you can't like share subscribe
help me out and there are other links in
the description to other things that i
do i have books available that you can
get through amazon or honestly you can
even go and get them from your local
bookstore library if you don't want to
give money to jeff bezos check that
stuff out in the description it's fun
but
you also don't have to
because
at the end of the day what i really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks to my highest supporting
patrons robin moore zimmerman fuller
barack the thing that goes doink in the
anime oliver b melinda walters andelke
the oath the boy bernabby lacks the
poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit angry
casper bookworm adam rdl taylor shane
ross ben borlay brendan the rose and tt
you want to hear me possibly butcher
your name check out the rewards on the
patreon
and thanks to all you folks
[Music]
um
[Music]